FRANCESC CAMPOY: Welcome
to the fifth episode
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy and I'm
here with my co-host, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey,
Francesc, how you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty
good, pretty good.
So today we're
going to be talking
with someone from Google.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Product manager that
is responsible for the
welfare experience.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Chris Sells.
Very excited, as per usual
for all our interviews.
I think it's going to be an
interesting podcast that's
going to sort of look
into the hows and whys we
make the decisions that we do.
And sort of give you
some opportunities
to provide feedback so you can
help direct things as well.
So that's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it's going to be
quite interesting to interview
someone that has such an
interesting view of the tech
industry in general.
He's been working so many cool
companies that-- his opinion,
by itself, is amazing.
The fact that he has the
power of changing Google Cloud
Platform Podcast-- Google
Cloud Platform, sorry--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --and
the way we use it.
Even more interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Even
more interesting.
But let's talk about
cool things of the week.
There's been a really
nice launch recently
that I think is quite
interesting and exciting.
Custom machine types.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Custom machine
types, what is that?
So far we've talked during one
of our first episodes actually
about Google Compute Engine and
how you can create instances.
So basically those are
VMs and they have-- we
used to have-- we still
have them, actually--
a list of types of
machines that you can get.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
can get, for instance,
the standard one which
is-- what's the name again?
MARK MANDEL: N1-standard-1.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: N1-standard-1
or standard-1-N1.
Where basically what
you're saying is,
I want one core
and a decent amount
of memory, not too
much, not too little.
And then we also have with
two cores, four, eight, 16,
out to 32.
And then you can
choose if you want
the more CPU or more memory.
But that was pretty much it.
So if you wanted,
for instance, to get
a machine that had 32
CPUs but you didn't really
want that much memory because
you were doing something that
was really, really computation
heavy but not that much memory,
you didn't really
have an option.
MARK MANDEL: It's
kind of cookie cutter.
You know, you've got a
one size fits all so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: To a degree.
More than one size.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Many very
different sizes but not enough.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we've
basically fixed glitch.
So we have it now, when
you create a new instance,
you actually have
in the menu a way
to choose between
either the default types
or you can create your own type.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
That sounds cool.
So I can basically say,
this is how much CPU I want,
this is how much memory
I want, and I can custom
fit it basically to
whatever my needs are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Exactly.
So you're going to
have two sliders,
one is going to be for
the number of CPUs--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--the other one is
going to be for that
size of the memory.
That's it.
And you choose
whatever you need.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds really awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And the best part
is the price of
[INAUDIBLE] to that.
So if you're going to use
less memory, you pay less.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: So also, if I
was running my own machines,
maybe on-prem or
something like that,
and I want to try and
match those in some way,
I could be, like, oh, now
I can built my machine
spec to match that exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
And also what I was thinking
is that you can also do tests
on it and see,
for instance, what
is the minimum amount of
memory that you need--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --on your app.
So you can do that.
Just [INAUDIBLE], do
some tests, and see
how it behaves, and do it on
different kinds of missions
to actually be sure that the
instances that you're using
are the best suited for
what you want to do.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
OK.
That sounds super,
super powerful.
We've got a link
in the show notes,
see the blog post that
describes this, and obviously
the documentation as well.
So that sounds really great.
So why don't we get into
our interview with Chris.
It sounds like it's
going to be great too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Let's go for that.
MARK MANDEL: Brilliant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
here with Chris Sells.
Hi, Chris.
CHRIS SELLS: Hey, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you
are a product manager here
at Google Cloud Platform
for development experience.
So tell us a little bit
about what does that mean.
CHRIS SELLS: Sure.
So what that means,
fundamentally,
is-- well, let's see,
let me say it this way.
The old CEO at
Microsoft, he would
say-- he would leap
up on stage and say,
developers,
developers, developers.
That's what I do.
I care deeply about making sure
that developers on the Google
Cloud Platform have the
tools that they need
to be happy and successful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So developers, developers,
developers, and tools.
What are tools for you?
What are those tools
for developers?
CHRIS SELLS: Sure.
And in fact, that's actually
kind of an ongoing issue
because pretty much anything
that you can talk to
on our platform is a tool, from
the APIs, to the command lines,
to the web, to the
IDE extensions.
Right?
I mean, you can think
of anything as a tool.
But fundamentally, what
I care mostly about
is making sure that you have
a good way to write your code
to target our platform.
So that's bring your own
editor, that's use Eclipse,
use Android Studio, use
other IDEs that we either
plug-in directly or
work with, partners
like JetBrains to make
sure it'll work well.
That's bringing
in libraries that
work really well for
your particular language
and program against not
just the cloud APIs but all
of the Google APIs.
That's being able to
test your code locally,
make sure it runs the
way you would expect.
That means being able
to check-in your code.
to package your code
and deploy it to our platform.
And then once it's there,
being able to debug problems,
being able to look
at logs, being
able to just find
issues and fix them
and the cycle goes on and on.
That range of tools,
through the whole set
of developer lifecycle
for a piece of software,
that's the set of
things that I push on.
MARK MANDEL: So not much.
Not much at all.
[LAUGHTER]
Very little.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's a couple things.
MARK MANDEL: Couple things.
Not a very busy fellow really.
CHRIS SELLS: Well, it's
funny you say that.
But I feel pretty busy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's-- I'm not surprising
by that [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Shocking.
So there's a lot of different
things going on in there.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
are the last-- the
latest projects
you've been working on?
CHRIS SELLS: Sure.
So very proud, in
the last few months,
we have released
language specific
Getting Started pages for
the Google Cloud Platform
across four languages.
Up until now we've
been really good about,
hey, you want to learn about GCS
or Data Store, Cloud SQL or App
Engine or Compute Engine
from a product point of view.
But a lot of developers kind of
consider themselves by language
first.
Right?
For example, they go to
Google and they type, Node,
how do I, Python,
how do I, right?
I mean, that's--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
CHRIS SELLS: --how they
think of themselves, right?
I'm a Java developer,
I'm a Ruby developer.
And so we weren't
doing a very good job
of kind of thinking about
the end and development story
from how developers
identify themselves
from a specific language.
So what we've been
doing is thinking
about the set of
server side languages
that we really want to push
on and then making sure
that developers
have a place to go,
a home for that particular
language, on our platform.
And we've launched
four of those so far.
So if you go to cloud.google.com
/nojs/python/go/ruby,
you will get our first four
language starting pages.
Entry points into our
platform for those languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks.
So I'm assuming
that includes how
to use the APIs
idiomatically and so on.
CHRIS SELLS: It does.
It does.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Does it also include
things like, for instance, if
you're a Python programmer you
might be using
Flask, on how to use
those very popular
libraries on our platform?
CHRIS SELLS: [COUGHING].
Sorry.
That wasn't surprising,
I just had a cough.
[LAUGHTER]
So the answer is, for our
initial landing page--
we've got, for all four
of these languages,
we've got two samples.
Kind of a, Hello World,
what's the minimum you
need to do to bundle up
some code in that language
and get it running
on our platform.
And then we've got
a bigger sample
which takes you
through a tour of some
of the technologies
around our platform.
And that's what
we have right now.
And what we've done for
each one of these languages
is we've picked a
single framework.
For example, for
Ruby we picked Rails.
Of course, Node is
built right in, right?
That's the framework
we use there.
And we've started there.
Over time we have
all kinds of plans
to make sure we cover the
set of popular frameworks
and the set of popular tools
and, you know, I'm a Ruby-ist,
how do I do this and that
thing that I as a Ruby-ist
want to do and et cetera.
And we have big plans for
expanding that to cover those.
And then what I'd really love
to hear from your listeners
is what they would
like us to do.
What does a Ruby developer
want us to cover,
make sure that we have
instructions on how to do,
or Python or et cetera.
So that's part of why
I'm here, to kind of let
folks know that there is
somebody at Google watching
their backs as a developer from
all of this set of languages.
And if there is something
that you need from a tooling
point of view, I'm the
person you can reach out to,
and if I can't get
your question answered
or tell you where
we are on a feature,
then I can hook you
up with who can.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Nice.
So you mentioned
that four languages
got released on the Platform.
Of course, now I have to ask,
which one's your favorite?
CHRIS SELLS: Actually,
it's funny you ask that.
I, like every developer that's
ever picked up JavaScript,
have gone through my
five stages of grief.
Right?
I started at denial.
Oh, my Lord, I can't
believe somebody thinks this
is a real programming language.
And went through
anger and bargaining
and I went through
the whole thing,
and I eventually ended
up at acceptance.
Both from a client
programming point of view
and a server programming
point of view,
of that set of
languages, I would
have to say that now
it is my favorite.
JavaScript as my favorite.
You have no idea how hard it is
for me to admit that in public.
Hello, my name is Chris
Sells and I like JavaScript.
Right?
That's just--
MARK MANDEL: That's
just [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
CHRIS SELLS: And this is
after-- I mean, to be clear,
my language history, I spent
probably 10 years in C,
10 years in C++-- there was
an overlap there, of course.
And then I gave all of that up
for C# and I did C# for more
than a decade probably.
I've done a bunch of C#
work in the Windows world.
And then right before
I came over to Google,
there was a period
of a few years where
I did a bunch of JavaScript work
as part of Windows 8 developer
experience for JavaScript.
And that's where I
kind of picked it up.
And at one point--
I don't know how
you guys are but I dream in
code sometimes-- and I woke up
and I had to think, wait,
what language was that?
Because it was so natural.
I didn't know was it
JavaScript, was it C#?
And I knew that I had been
infected with JavaScript.
That's when I knew the
process was complete.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like the
idea of talking of JavaScript
from an infective point of view.
[LAUGHTER]
So you mentioned that you
tried to get feedback directly
from developers.
One way of getting
that, of course,
is developers going to
us and talking to you,
sending emails or--
CHRIS SELLS: Yes.
Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[INAUDIBLE] bugs and so on.
CHRIS SELLS: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What are
the other ways you find out
what had kind of features to add
or what kind of communication
to improve and so on?
CHRIS SELLS: Actually,
that's a really good question
because the fundamental
job of a PM here at Google
is to understand the customer
needs, and in many cases,
to be the customer proxy.
To bring in customer
requirements
and represent them to
the engineering team
and convince them that
this is a good way to go.
Because none of the engineers
work for me at Google.
I mean, it's not
like at Microsoft
where the PM got to say,
jump, and the engineers said,
how high?
That's not how it
works at Google at all.
It's very much
engineering centric.
So it's my job to have data.
And that data comes in the
form of-- we do surveys a lot,
we do something we call
critical user journeys where
we kind of layout an end
to end scenario and have
our customers with our
user experience researchers
work their way through
these scenarios
and see how well they do.
And we take both completion
metrics, which is quantitative,
and comments-- verbatims-- along
the way, which is qualitative.
So we lean on that
kind of data a lot.
And then we lean on
customer sentiment as well.
We get to see what people
are doing on Stack Overflow,
we get to see what people
are doing on Twitter,
we get to see what people are
doing on our Google Groups.
And all of that forms
the basis of, really,
a ton of data that
we've got that we
use to inform our decisions
about what to build
and when to build it
and how important it is
and how to focus our
product planning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice, indeed.
You mentioned
previously, you talked
about IDEs and some integration
and some partnerships.
Personally, I'm a huge
IntelliJ fan, I know that.
But can you tell us
some more about what's
happening in the IDE space,
maybe specifically IntelliJ
because I'm watching
that a little bit.
I'd love to hear more.
I'm sure there's a
broader spectrum of people
other than just
what I specifically
want to hear about.
CHRIS SELLS: Well, absolutely.
So we have-- we shipped at
the beginning of this year
an extension to
Android Studio called
Cloud Tools for Android Studio.
Although it's bundled
right into Android Studio,
you don't have to
install it separately,
it just comes out of the box.
But essentially,
what it enables is
you to be a full stack developer
inside of Android Studio.
You can build your
Android client,
you can build your
Java based GCP backend,
and we'll even build
a client library.
And as you change your backend,
we'll update the client library
and make sure that
if there's a change
then you don't get
a compiler error
and you get state incompletion
and things like that.
So we built that
into Android Studio
and that's been shipping
all of this year.
And we've found that
to be very popular.
But as you know, or maybe
you don't, the Android Studio
is in fact a fork of IntelliJ
Community Edition, the Open
Source.
MARK MANDEL: I knew it.
CHRIS SELLS: Yeah.
So I figured you would.
And so, as you
might imagine, it's
not very far for
us to go from, hey,
let's extend Android Studio,
to let's extend IntelliJ
all together.
And so, in fact, we
have a GitHub repository
with the source code of a
Cloud Tools for IntelliJ
that's in the works.
It's not as full-featured yet
as the Cloud Tools for Android
Studio but we're
working on it and we
hope to have that not only
updated in the repository
but to have a
binary distribution
by the end of the year so you
can actually deploy from inside
of IntelliJ to our platform.
And right now what the
IntelliJ plug-in does,
it actually attaches
to Cloud Debugger.
I don't know if you guys know
how Cloud Debugger works,
but for your listeners, the
way the Cloud Debugger works
is you have your running
Java application,
for example-- we're
talking about Java now--
but you have your running Java
application on our platform,
and there's some
hard to find bug that
only happens in production.
You can't reproduce it on
your development machine,
you can't reproduce
it internally,
these are the ones
that kill you.
That now you're adding-- you're
inserting printf statements
every other line to figure
out what's going on.
And so what we do in
the Cloud Debugger
is you can actually pull up the
source code for the application
in production and set what is
the equivalent of a breakpoint,
except we don't actually break.
We never stop the process.
We don't-- in fact, the
user can't even tell.
We make sure that we don't
spend more than 10 milliseconds
grabbing data-- and
that's the call stack
and that's the locals-- so
that you can take that data
and dig into it as much as
you want to without harming
the user experience.
And you can track down what
the problem is that only
happens in production.
Now, that works all great on the
cloud, but for that to happen,
of course, you need to
give us your source code.
So in a lot of cases, we
find that our customers are
enterprise customers and
they don't have permission
to give us our source code,
right-- their source code.
So the nice thing about
the IntelliJ plug-in
is it works against
the source code you've
got on your local
machine but it never
makes it to the Google Cloud.
So you can do all of your
debugging for the Cloud
Debugger inside of
IntelliJ without giving us
your source code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's very cool.
That's a really fine point
I didn't actually realize.
Wow.
OK.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
very interesting.
So I have another
question regarding IDEs.
I'm a Go developer-- I
do Go most of the time--
and I was pretty excited to
hear that there was for--
and I actually, you used to work
at Microsoft so you may know
a lot about that-- so Visual
Studio-- Visual Studio
code-- has been open sourced.
CHRIS SELLS: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This
is a very interesting--
very interesting project.
And I know that, for instance,
they added support for Go
with debuggers and so on.
Like, probably they announced it
last week, something like that.
Is there any effort
that we are working--
we are working to have support
for Google Cloud Platform on VS
code?
And if not, is that something
that our community could do
or how does that work?
CHRIS SELLS: So
it's interesting.
So let's back up and think
about the technology involved.
One piece of technology
is, of course--
if we think about that
end to end developers
set of scenarios that I
care about, one of them
is having a set of
idiomatic client libraries.
Client libraries that
really work well.
And we already have-- there's
something like 267 Google
APIs-- we already have NuGet
libraries to cover the APIs
and we have a great deal, very
non-trivial amount of usage,
through .NET clients today using
Google APIs and Google Cloud
APIs.
So that's already one
part of the story.
You can go to NuGet, you
can grab those libraries,
you can bring them in
your project today.
OK?
We also have the fact that we
have the Compute Engine that
runs Windows Server.
Of course you could
imagine deploying
you know your ASP.NET app to
that Windows Server, right?
It's built right
into Windows Server.
There's nothing to stop you
from doing that kind of thing.
And of course we also have the
cloud SDK that, in addition
to working on Linux
and Mac, of course
we have a Windows Installer
and you can install and use
that today.
So we already do quite a bit for
the .NET developer on Windows.
So getting back
to your question,
are we going to
dig into VS code?
That's actually--
let me ask that
as a question to the audience.
Because VS code is interesting
because it is essentially
kind of Microsoft's
lightweight IDE-less IDE.
It's kind of like subline
text with debugging and built
in support for C#.
That's a good way
to think about it.
It is not at all like
the heavyweight IDE
that Visual Studio
is on Windows.
And the question is, how
important is that integration
to our audience?
Is that something that they
think is high on their list?
Do they want to do C# .NET based
development on a Mac, on Linux?
Or do they want to fire it up
on Windows using the full Visual
Studio desktop?
Right now it seems pretty clear
that the usage is Visual Studio
desktop, but I'm curious
what the adoption will be--
and of course, based on that
then, how quickly we should
think about supporting it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a very
good question that I cannot
really answer.
MARK MANDEL: No.
And then again, like
you were saying,
you want to reach
to the audience
and we'll definitely put
all your contact details
in the show notes so that you
can have those conversations
and we can find
those things out.
Because that's important
information to have.
CHRIS SELLS: Absolutely.
And this is part of how
I gather that data to be
able to make product decisions.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds really cool.
So now I'm curious
whether-- so I
know there is new and
interesting stuff coming up
in the roadmap.
I'm wondering if you're
able to share anything
or at least tease a little
on what sort of cool things
might be coming.
I know we all work at Google.
I feel terrible asking.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool
but not confidential.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cool but no confidential
thinks we're
going to get in trouble for.
Yeah.
I'm sure our listeners would
love to see what's coming.
CHRIS SELLS: Sure.
So on the language
pages, I already
mentioned that we
want to do a lot more.
Essentially we have a
minimal getting started.
We want to do a lot more there
in terms of content and tools
and just making that a place
where that programmer can
go and get all the information
they need about our platform,
or at least references
to the right resources.
We also-- these aren't the
only languages we want to do.
Java is coming.
Of course, it's a very important
language for our platform.
As well as PHP.
PHP is also in the
pipeline there.
So those are coming
down from us.
You can also
expect-- I mentioned
Cloud Debugging for Java.
We've got more
languages coming there.
So that's coming
down the pipeline.
Trying to think what
else I can tell you.
As it turns out, right now and
probably the last two weeks
of my life and probably
the next two weeks,
has all been consumed
with 2016 planning.
And at Google, essentially
what that means
is we throw everything
up in the air
and we think about
really what we
want to do, what kind of
impact did we do, did we
move the needle in 2015,
how did we move the needle,
did we move it as much as
we thought we were going to?
And then in 2016,
what do we want to do?
How do we take that set of
engineering and PM and user
experience resources
and figure out
what we should do
in the next year
to make sure that
our customer gets
the absolute most from the
limited set-- unfortunately
limited set-- of resources
that they possibly can.
And so now I'm
thinking, there are
a lot of possibilities of
things that are coming in 2016
and I'm trying to
think if I have
any certainty of any of them.
I think I'm--
[LAUGHTER]
I think I might have been
as certain already in terms
of what I know is coming
which is debugging
and the two new languages
and deployment support
from IntelliJ.
So I've told you probably
more than I should already,
to be frank.
MARK MANDEL: Good
for our listeners.
They appreciate that.
Wonderful.
OK.
Well, as you said,
you want to get in--
have people get in
contact with you.
Do you want to just give us a
little rundown on ways people
can get in contact with you?
We'll obviously put
that in the show notes
but I'd like to have it here as
well so that people will know.
CHRIS SELLS: Sure.
First and foremost,
my Google email.
Csells-- C as in Charlie, S
as in Sam, E-L-L-S as in Sam--
@google.com.
And in fact, it's interesting.
I knew that Google was
a good place for me
to come because that
alias was available.
Every single internet email
at every single company
I've worked with, I was csells@.
So csells@microsoft.com,
csells@intel.com,
csells@google.com.
I knew there was a home for
me because that alias was
available.
So that was the good news.
I'm also @csells on Twitter.
I'm a big Twitter fan.
I guess I'm on Facebook but
I haven't been to Facebook
in so long I couldn't
actually tell you.
Maybe they expire you.
I don't know.
And then my vanity website--
I've had a blog since before we
called it blogging,
since '95 actually--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Impressive.
CHRIS SELLS: At
sellsbrothers.com.
And it started as
a single static web
page with a bunch of links
to Windows developer tools
and resources when
I used to teach.
And I couldn't
remember all this stuff
so I would just have
it on a web page
that I could give
to my students.
And it is now a blog that
I have written three,
four times over
based on whatever
the current set of technologies
was that I was working with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
language is it written in now?
CHRIS SELLS: As
of right now I've
actually moved it over
to a hosted service which
is-- it's called Blot.
And it's awesome
because, essentially, I
add a file to Dropbox
and press the Save button
and my blog is
updated immediately.
And it's awesome.
I'm a huge fan.
But to answer your
question, I had
all of that in
ASP.NET and SQL Server
and so I wrote a ton of
data transformation software
to pull it all out
of that and drop it
into nice, neat files
on my hard drive
so that Dropbox
could pick it up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Is there any forum
where people can
discuss the kind of
features they want
and all of these things?
Is that-- maybe Google
Groups or something
like that that they could chat?
CHRIS SELLS: So we have
one of those in the works
and we have some plans for that.
And so if people are interested
in being on that group,
they can drop me a line
and I can make sure
that they're in the
initial seed list.
As part of as we grow out
these language specific sites,
we want to have a discussion
group where people can just
drop in and have
those conversations.
So I'm maintaining that
list of initial people
to go into those
that new discussion
group we're setting up so
people can drop me a line--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
CHRIS SELLS: --there.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, before we wrap up,
Chris, is there anything
else you want to mention
or talk about or plug
that we haven't covered so far?
CHRIS SELLS: I'm
trying to think.
Yeah.
The-- well, yes, there
is one thing, which is--
MARK MANDEL: OK.
CHRIS SELLS: --where have you
guys been for the last year
that I was at Google?
MARK MANDEL: I
only joined in May.
I've got no other
excuse than that.
CHRIS SELLS: So--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I was busy waiting for
someone to help me with this.
CHRIS SELLS: So when
I joined Google--
whenever I pick up a new
technology like JavaScript--
when I picked up
JavaScript I went
and I subscribed to-- I
figured out the right web pages
and I figured out
the right RSS feeds
the right podcast.
And I would spend
my free minutes
during my commute listening
to the podcast as a way
to get up to speed on whatever
the new technology was.
And honestly, listening
to the jQuery podcast
helped me get over the
hump for JavaScript.
And so when I came to this
platform a year ago-- of course
I was familiar with cloud
computing in general
and had built distributed
software for years and years--
but this whole new world of
the Google Cloud Platform
and-- you know, I gave
up my Windows machine
and came over to a Mac and
I had a Linux desktop--
where were you guys to help me
kind of make it over that hump
as I was learning
all that stuff?
You're late but better
late than never.
I'm very happy to have you here.
I've been listening to
you guys on my commute.
It's been super useful.
And so from the community,
thank you, guys, very much.
I know how hard this
is, how much work it is,
so thank you very
much for this work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
thank you for helping us
with this episode today.
CHRIS SELLS: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we'll
let you know any questions
that we get from our listeners.
We'll send them directly to you.
Well, thank you, Chris, that
was an awesome interview.
MARK MANDEL: That was great.
I really enjoyed that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I learned a lot.
Very happy to have him,
finally, on this podcast.
And very happy that he
liked us so much really.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Yes.
Super happy about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's an honor.
So let's go for the
last part of the episode
with the question of the week.
The question of the week today,
it's related to Kubernetes
So we talked about it
with-- in episode number two
with Brain Dorsey-- and one of
the things that we discussed
was [INAUDIBLE]
controllers which basically
allows you to say
how many instances
or how many replicas
of a given bot
or set of containers
you want to have.
And the question
that we received
was, well, yeah, that's fine,
but does it also autoscale?
Like, will it create
more instances
if I have more traffic or
any other requirements?
So do you know that?
MARK MANDEL: I do know this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: This is a question
I get quite regularly whenever
I present about Kubernetes.
So the really cool thing is
is several weeks ago-- not
too long ago now--
Kubernetes 1.1 was released,
and one of the great
new features about that
is horizontal pod order scaling.
Which is awesome.
It does literally exactly
what you would describe.
You're able to configure it
such that to create and decrease
the number of pods
that are running
or the number of containers
that are running.
The way it works is
through CPU order scaling.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So the number--
I'm going to make sure
I read this right because
it's mathematical.
The CPU utilization is
the recent CPU usage
of a pod divided by the
sum of CPU requested
by the pod's containers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I mad sure I read that right.
So basically, the
short gist of it
is, is you say
things like, I want
a minimum number of
replicas-- say, one--
I want a maximum number
of replicas-- so, 10--
and then you say, OK.
The target percentage
is, say, 50,
so you want to make
sure that the CPU
usage stays under that 50%.
And so if you start
going over it,
it will start creating
pods to make sure
that CPU usage comes down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see.
MARK MANDEL: So you're
able to do cool stuff so
that you can load
test application,
make sure that CPU
usage is right,
you can create the number
of pods that you need
and then you can say,
OK, can we handle
a million requests per
second or whatever it is you
might actually have to need.
It's pretty straightforward.
And again, it's
through a YAML file,
very standard stuff
is Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
very interesting.
So that's something
quite new you said?
MARK MANDEL: It is.
It came in the 1.1 release.
It's part of the extensions
beta type stuff, which is still
in Invader in Kubernetes.
But definitely worth
playing with it.
It's going to be a very
powerful new feature.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
I can totally see
that being Kubernetes
such an active community.
Not only this will be included
soon but also, I'm hoping,
we'll have something similar for
memory usage and other metrics.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There's so many options
there from Kubernetes
for order scaling.
But so glad to
see this come out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: That's great.
Right.
Well, Fransesc,
where are you going
to be in the next few months?
Are you traveling anywhere?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm going
to be-- I'm going to be home.
I'm actually--
MARK MANDEL: The
end of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm actually going to be
is San Francisco enjoying
this beautiful
city for a change.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
My next trip, other than
holidays, which will be-- I'm
going to spend my holidays
somewhere really far
away and really far away from
my computer-- after that I
will go to [INAUDIBLE].
So it's these really cool
conference late January
in Brussels.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, I--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
going to be in Canada.
I mentioned it a few times,
DevFest in Vancouver.
After that I'm not going
anywhere for a while.
Maybe I'll plan a trip back
to Australia for a bit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
When is Vancouver?
When are you going to be there?
MARK MANDEL: That's
the 12th of December.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
going to be so cold.
MARK MANDEL: It's
going to be really.
I don't know what
I was thinking.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
enjoy your time there.
MARK MANDEL: I will.
I will.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Don't freeze.
Talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.